in science we have a kind of a crisis
out of two billion kids on this planet
roughly a billion kids live in poverty
that's half the world's talent that has
absolutely no access
and so for me
the idea has been to make science
accessible to everybody
[Music]
name is manu prakash i'm a faculty of
bioengineering at stanford university
and i'm an inventor
i happen to grow up in india and
i know what it means to not have access
to science
i remember
in exams we were asked to draw a
microscope although we had never touched
or seen one
and at that time i decided to make one
of course i didn't know how it worked so
the very first microscope i built was
out of cardboard tubes
and my brother's eyeglasses
that sort of instilled this idea that if
you don't have what you need you should
build it
if you talk about environmental
challenges climate change you talk about
biodiversity loss much of the challenges
that we face in our society depend on
understanding the microscopic world
so we developed an origami microscope
that you fold together
by folding a piece of paper it costs us
less than a dollar to build it's
portable it weighs less than 10 grams
anybody can carry it in their pocket
at this point they're half a million
units out there so they're half a
million eyes looking at this invisible
world
that we have often ignored
there are lots of people who followed
that work and built upon our work to
actually take it in new directions that
we'd never imagined
[Music]
much of the biggest scientific problems
in the world can't just be solved by
sitting in a lab
this is the aha moment
they require a global community of
people passionate about actually
tackling these problems
there is a sense of activism in what we
try to do
and
there is a call to action which is
let's engage
tools will come and go but it's these
communities that we're trying to enable
that will really stand the test of time
you